amanda is with us in Phoenix
hi Amanda how are you good how are you
better than I deserve what's up I'm
calling Tanaka I will embarrass I've
been a deep breathing listener for a
long time but I cannot stop using my
credit card and I don't know how to do
it I it's because for example if I go to
the store and I seem like that kind of
things I think I in my mind I think well
if I buy them and I take them home and I
don't want to keep them and I put it on
a credit card I can take it back without
it um
affecting what's in my checking account
so I don't know how to stop you do that
and then this I feel like a hypocrite
because I want to be I'm 34
I'm a credit cards do you have one one
what is it just a visa yes okay have you
got a pair of scissors yes I do I'll get
them out I know I know let's cut it off
right now
cut it up right now and close the
account what do you do if you um like
what if you do I just don't know how
like for example um we just got
insulation and our hepatic um we have
the money for it but it's easier to just
put on a credit card to like not have to
pay like right now no it's not it's
easier to pay right now yeah I just feel
like it I don't know I yeah I just is I
think it's like a I'm having a really
hard time making that mind shift I've
thought about kind of my credit card but
it really breaks me out
hmm so I don't know which it should not
really should freak you out that it
freaks you out that you're that
emotionally dependent on a piece of
plastic how lame a statement is that I
know right yeah and also um I think I
feel like we are studying them
and um means we need to use a credit
card to scaffold us or you know budget
um no no my husband about you too
I know all right yeah I just I just saw
loaded that um I don't think you're a
hypocrite because I don't think you're
working any of our stuff yeah I think
you just a casual radio listener is okay
but if it's time to graduate and
actually do the stuff then maybe debate
today right exactly yes I I want to I
feel like we're we had the only thing we
have is a credit card
ya know I'm making progress I know we're
not she does you still feel a lot of
control I do and I that's the part
that's frustrating to me because I don't
feel like we're getting anywhere and I
feel like we're every month it's like
well you feel that way is just the truth
yeah you're not getting anywhere if
you're out of control you don't have a
system you're not living on a budget and
you buy crap at Target on your credit
card promising is going to take it back
and then you don't right exactly yeah
and so you know how is it working for
you right good okay this time to change
isn't it right exactly
okay so let's download every dollar okay
you got an iPhone or a droid iPhone okay
jump on iTunes and download the every
dollar app and then sit down with your
husband tonight you guys do a budget and
get you know you're gonna have to do
that because you're going to cut up your
credit card right now if you got your
scissors out yet I don't want it in my
car I am I will I will cut up tonight
you got a debit card I do can do
everything you want to with a debit card
I'm and had a credit card in 25 years
and I'm perfectly healthy yes I know I
just it I don't know like I just feel
like yes you don't know okay I know that
it's not good to happen and I know I
mean you know the just equation is that
the thing is this
there's a saying we have this is until
the pain of same
is greater than the pain of change you
won't change until you are sitting deep
enough and do do that you will do
something about it you're not going to
change great and I don't want you to
actually have financial problems due to
your misbehavior before you actually
change I'd rather you just have
emotional angst like you do right now
like feeling like you need to do this
and I want that to just blow up inside
your head right now for your sake I
don't care it doesn't affect me all
right now I'm gonna you know I'm going
to talk to Diana from Des Moines in a
minute my life is going too long so the
question is what are you going to do to
fix your life are you going to do
something different so that you get a
different result right that's I need to
cut it today all right I will have you
got have you got Total Money Makeover
the book I do good okay we'll get it out
yeah okay yeah let's hat no let's just
have a come-to-jesus
on the money meeting tonight with a
husband and the you to sit down turn off
the TV but to get to bed and let's just
talk baby it's time to change it's time
to do something new it's time to have a
new life a better life and we're going
to take some action to cause that to
happen and I think you can do it I think
you know exactly what to do you know
you're not nearly as helpless as you
like to sound like you are you can do
this you're a lot stronger than your
sound then you want to sound like you
are you know exactly what to do and you
know exactly how to do it and you know
what you're currently doing is not
working so you know you need to change
so I think you can do it if I can help
you call me back anytime
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]